hi I'm an architect and this picture
shows the city that I come from Beijing
China and
out Beijing is like a very beautiful
garden can see a lot of nature when I
was a kid I learned swim in this lake
and a climb mountains every day after
school but after I think getting older
we built a more and more modern
buildings and they all look the same it
all looked like match boxes
why modern buildings and cities a few of
these
boxy shapes in this photo that you
actually see two cities one on the left
is in New York and then one under on the
right is a changing a Chinese city
that's being constructed and they have a
very similar skylines maybe they also
follow the same principle you know
competing for density competing for more
space competing for efficiency
therefore modern architecture they
become symbol of capital and power
Chinese cities are building a lot they
also you know not only competing for
this space and the height also learning
a lot from a North American urban
strategies also repeat a lot from city
to city so here we call one thousand
city with one face
so as an architect in China I have to
ask myself what can I do about it
one day I was walking on the street I
saw you know people selling fish and
they put a fish in this cube big fish
tank so I was asking the same question
why a cubic space for fish do they like
cubic space
obviously not so maybe the cubic space
cubic architecture is cheaper it's
easier to make
so I did this is a small research I the
camera and I tried to observe how fish
behave in this cubic space and then I
find they probably
wasn't happy the cubic space were then
the perfect home for them so I decided
to design a new fish tank for them I
think it should be more organic it
should be more fluid space inside and
more complex
interiors I
think they should feel happier leaving
this space but I wouldn't know because
they don't talk to
but one year after we got this
opportunity to design this real building
for humans this actually a pair of tower
that we built in Mississauga at a city
outside Toronto
and people call this the Marilyn Monroe
Towers
because of its curvature
and the idea was to build a tower
high-rise residential tower but not a
box it's more inspired by nature with
the sunshine and wind dynamics
after we finished designing the first
tower and
they told us you know you
don't have to design a second one you
just repeat the same design and we pay
you ties
but I said you cannot have a to Marilyn
Monroe standing there
and
nature never repeat itself so now we're
having two buildings that you know they
can dance together
so I have I have this question for
myself
you know why in the modern city we often
think architecture is a machine is a box
so here I want to see how people look at
the nature in the past by looking into
this Chinese traditional painting I find
that they often mixed the nature and the
artificial men
in the very dramatic way so they create
this emotional scenery so in the modern
city my question is is there a way that
we don't separate in buildings and the
nature but combine them
so this is another project that we built
in China is a quite large
residential complex and it's located in
a very beautiful nature setting to be
honest the first time when I really
decide was too beautiful and you know I
I almost decided to reject the project
because you know it's if you criminal
you know to to to anything there I
don't want to become criminals
but my second thought was if I didn't do
it they would just put you know standard
urban towers there anyway and that would
be pity so I decided I had to give a try
so the way we did that was we took the
contour lines from the existing
mountains and we took those lines and
the translated into a building so those
powers actually taking the shapes and
geometry is from the nature so each
building has a different shape a
different size different height and they
become the extension of the other nature
they still eat it and
you know people think we use computers
sometime to design this kind of
architecture but I actually use a lot of
a hand sketch because I like the the
randomness in the hand sketch and they
can carry sort of emotions that cannot
be made by computers
architecture and human and nature can
co-exist together and having good
relationship in this photo or actually
this guy in the photo is one of the
architects are our team I think he's
been you know enjoying the beautiful
nature scenery and and the feeling
relief that there is another part of a
criminal's
in the end
back to the city in Beijing we were
asked to design these urban towers and I
made this model its architecture model
look like mini mountain and the meaning
values and put this model on my table
and I water it every day and
years later we complete this a building
and you can see how this my hand sketch
being translated into real building and
they look quite similar
it looks like a black mountain and this
is how these buildings
situated in the city is on the edge of
this a beautiful park it's a different
very different from the surrounding
buildings because other buildings
they're trying to build a wall around
the nature but what we're trying to do
here is to make the building itself as a
part of nature so we can extend the
nature from the park into the city so
that was the idea a
Chinese critic art critic he draw this
painting he put our building in this
painting
can you see this a black tiny tiny
Mountain that's that's that looked very
fit into this painting
however in this reality our design being
challenged that they look so different
from the surroundings and they asked me
to modify my design either color or
shape to make the building fit the
contacts more better
so my question was why it fits this
traditional you know natural context
better than the reality may be something
wrong with the reality something wrong
with the context
in the very northern part of the China
we also build this opera house at the
Opera House next to the river in the
wetland park so it is a design to make
this building part of the surrounding
landscape and the merge node to the
horizon
the building literally looked like a
Snow Mountain and and people can walk on
the building and during the day or when
there's no opera people come here they
can enjoy the views and they can
continue their journey from the park
onto the building
when they reach the rooftop there's an
vo theatre that framing the sky where
they can sing to the sky
inside opera we have this lobby with a
lot of natural light and they can also
enjoy this semi indoor outdoor space and
they can see the beautiful view around
them
I've been building several mountains and
here and trying to show you one building
I think it look like a cloud it's a
Lucas Museum of a narrative art that's
being constructed in city of Los Angeles
it's a museum that created by George
Lucas
the creator of Star Wars
why why building look like a cloud
because I think I imagine the cloud is a
mysterious it's a nature
it's surreal when this natural element
landed in the city and it makes you feel
curious about her attentive you know
wants to explore it
so
that's how building landed on Earth by
lifting this museum making it you know
floating above the ground we can free up
a lot of landscape and the space
underneath the building and then we can
same time create that is a roof garden
above the building where you can visit
and and enjoy the view this museum will
be completed in year 2022 and you're out
invited when is
completed
so after building all these you know
mountains and clouds now we're building
this volcanoes
back in China this is actually a huge
sports park with the four stadiums in it
with one stadium football stadium and
40,000 seats in there
so it's a very large project and you see
from this photo you know you can hardly
tell where the building where is a
landscape so the building become
landscape even become a land art where
people can walk around the building and
they can climb this building as it a
wandering in this volcano park and
this rendering shows one of the space in
those volcanoes this is actually a
swimming pool with natural light coming
from above
so what we're trying to create actually
is the environment that lures a boundary
in between architecture and nature so
architecture is no longer functional
machine for living it also reflect the
nature around us it also reflect our
soul and the spirit
so as architect I don't think you know
in the future we should repeat those
soulless match boxes anymore I think
what I'm looking for the opportunity is
to create a future with harmony in
between human and nature thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]